[Music]
bro I cannot believe you're about to see
this but Brendan shop shot back at Rogan
so you remember this clip this is
everyone strapping you remember this
clip it's it Brandon Shaw he gave his
opinion on Dana that alive like piranhas
it's so dumb I didn't talk to him about
that but first of all he's wrong yeah he
needed that he's wrong about the theory
he look Brennan's my boy but he needs a
Handler he needs someone like me around
him all the time what are you gonna do
no no no here's why yeah and he'll go
yeah you're right and then now here you
go he's replying to Rogan I cannot
believe this probably a reason was
invited to sober October the thing I
think that hurts me even more is Dana
lies about it
and then by your mommy oh dude come on
that you saying Dana would actually do
that UFC 279
Brendan needs a Handler
and now he's making fun of Rogan's face
seriously he's doing the Rogan mouth
open the watch watch and Brendan needs a
Handler
[Laughter]
do I
yes yes next question or does your boy
need a Handler
who's this boy
he's saying does your boy Dana White
need a Handler he's telling Rogan does
your boy need a Handler no he's actually
doing pretty well for himself yeah
pretty good
you should have ran that by me okay he
okay he's doing that bit again he's
doing he's doing the is it it's it's the
what we calling Will Sasso well no the
will Sasser was when he like goes
through no hesitating but when he does
this this is
Chris I was gonna say Chris Delia okay
Chrisley all right he's like everybody
he does a show with he just steals from
them do I or does your boy need a watch
watch this part you should have ran that
by me you should have ran that by me
what was that oh that's Jack Nicholson
Joker impression
it's pretty good
Mark Harley in the background giggling
as [ __ ] Brennan bites the hand that
feeds is the perfect quotation mark dude
Mark Harley I I'm I'm turning around on
him the way I turned around on kalila I
love him because they're destroying
these people Mark Carly's destroying
Brendan's job Rich billionaire not even
a millionaire liking something and uh
in people's ear like you know he's like
that terrible agent or manager like you
hype and you're like that tells you like
nah man you are the whole [ __ ] show
you don't need these [ __ ] guys you
don't need any of these people you're
the man they're the ones taking
advantage of your talent bro you know
what I mean like he's the guy that gets
all in his head and he's like yeah [ __ ]
Rogan bro what the [ __ ] dude I only do I
don't need Dana White in the UFC I mean
I only do 90 MMA content but [ __ ] them
with these [ __ ]
and then Dan be like yeah do it and the
people
yes yes
and in what world is this what world are
we living and then the other thing I
think that hurts me even more is Dana
lies about it
and then by your mommy oh dude come on
that you saying Dana would actually do
that you'll see 279 Brendan needs a
Handler
do I or does your boy need a Handler
you're the biggest joke in the comedy
scene and on the internet
you are the one look whether you like
Dana White or don't Dana White owns one
of the most successful Sports businesses
in the world ever that's ever existed so
yeah you need a Handler no Dana White is
still [ __ ] selling out every show he
does all right you have to do five takes
to do a 26 26 minute YouTube special
about how much you like Mexican food
yeah bro they try to shut everything
down due to covet and this [ __ ]
said I'm buying an island yeah yeah and
you know what he did he tried to get
blow jobs from everybody on trash
Tuesday in the [ __ ] parking lot of
The Comedy Store
I'm not the one playing grab after his
Mark Zuckerberg letting them ran out
thick boy Studios shutting it down
whoa what
what is he talking about I don't know
that was a little letting him rent out
thick boy Studios but then it's not your
Studios so if letting him rent out
stickers too you didn't think what is he
talking about he said he's not the one I
think he's implying that Joe Rogan is
rented out his Studio to Zuckerberg was
Mark Zuckerberg letting him ran out
thick boy Studios shutting it down
for his entertainment you should have
ran that by me
or what
you you are the man like I've said this
before Bernard shops the only guy that
could kick my ass and I would respect
him less for it afterwards I I've never
seen somebody that could kick my ass and
I just just look at him and go man I
don't respect you in any way you're not
funny but then now you're but as Mercer
you said it perfectly you're gonna sit
here and bite the hand that feeds you
not only that dude but I didn't start it
you could tell this is all starting to
really get to him because the the more
this is eating at him the more cool he's
trying to sound like I'm just having a
fun time with this like it's eating it's
bothering him he's trying to put a good
face on and it's not he's not doing a
good job of it okay Brandon whatever you
do act natural branding acting natural
he looks like that's the look of a man
who just put something in your dream
yeah
I was literally about to say if you
looked up date rape in the dictionary
that's the [ __ ] picture
you want another drink are you thirsty
hey Brendan did you spike my drink no no
he is date raped by Sublime with Rome
the person
sorry sorry that's the face you make
where you've you've sipped at the drink
he's given
oh
Brandon would be the idiot though that
mixes up her drink with his drink and
then he just ends up passed out on the
bar by the way him winking all cocky
you're gonna have a riff with Joe Rogan
and it's going to be one of the funniest
things I've ever seen in my life should
have ran that by me wink right I don't
need a Handler
these guys need a Handler somebody
should have gotten the air of Dana and
Mark Zuckerberg went hey hey you two
Rich privileged
all right so like Anyway this thing got
this covering it yeah and I don't care
[Laughter]
what are you what are you doing he's
turning everything to the ground